Just a couple of implementation notes, and first a quick mental exercise.
What happens if 2 different paths reach the same vertex at the same time?
So let's consider this graph here.
We're going to start at node S here, and we're going to set its depth to zero
on the first iteration of our algorithm, then the depth of A will be set to 1 and the depth of B will be set to 1,
but we know in the next iteration of the algorithm this edge and this edge will both try to set Cs depth.
Is this a race condition? Does the result depend on which thread happens to run first?
Well, fortunately no, because the algorithm is structured
to always write only a singe depth value on any iteration,
so if 2 threads are both trying to write to the same vertex within a single iteration,
they'll always both be writing the same depth.
In this case, they'll both be trying to write the value 2, so it doesn't really matter who goes first or second,
because the end result, the depth of C, is going to be the same.
Second, how do we know when we're done?
So typically the way we're going to write this code is as follows.
We're going to check a variable to see if we're done, and we're going to check that variable on the host.
That variable's going to be set on the device. The kernel needs to set that variable.
Then we'll copy it at the end of every iteration to the host. The host will check if we're done.
If we're not done, we're going to iterate again.
If we are done, then we'll fall through the loop and move on to the next code.
So how do we actually set this variable?
So, in this case, what we're going to do is we're going to first initialize a device variable called done to true.
The way we're going to initialize it is we're going to have a variable on the host we know is true
and just copy it over to the device so it's set as true at the beginning,
then we're going to run our iteration, run this particular kernel,
and if the kernel knows that it's not done yet, it will take this done variable and set it to false.
Then, whatever the state of the done variable is, will copy it back to the host,
and so the host will then know if we're complete or not and make a decision accordingly.
So how are we going to actually do this on a GPU? What's inside the kernel?
So this is an enhancement to the code that we just saw on the previous slide.
What we're going to do is every time we set any vertex depth on the GPU,
we also, alongside, set the global variable done to false
so it's initialized to true if we make no changes at all in this BFS code,
then it will stay true and we'll be done. But if we make any changes at all,
then we'll set that global variable to false, then we will copy that false variable back to the host,
and it will give us another iteration.
Note that more than one thread can set done to false, but that's fine.
It doesn't matter in what order these writes occur since they're all going to be the same value.